Chicago's Cook County Jail releasing
over 1300 inmates to prevent the spread
of Cova 19 the facility is a coronavirus
hotspot with one of the largest clusters
in the nation Matt Finn is live in
Chicago and Matt we've seen this happen
in other cities as well it is a big big
issue good morning Edie cities
nationwide are releasing prisoners and
detainees saying that the corona virus
is spreading so fiercely inside of
prisons they basically have no choice
but to release people to make room and
potentially save lives the Cook County
prison here in Chicago at one point was
considered the nation's greatest hot
spot for Kovan 19 detainees are now
putting up signs in the window saying
don't let us die and we matter right now
three people have already died from the
corona virus at the Cook County prison
and there are more than 500 cases of
corona virus inside the facilities 306
inmates 218 staff that have to go home
to their family the Cook County public
defender's office tells FOX News it's
holding emergency hearings and has
released at least 1300 prisoners and a
teeny so far and identified at least 80
more eight that are seriously ill the
sheriff tells Fox News the public
defender is releasing it to Petain ease
within certain criteria some that are
elderly have a serious medical condition
or are considered nonviolent offenders
the public defender says up to 90
percent of detainees in the Cook County
Jail are considered in a sense they are
pretrial and they are being released
with the public safety in mind
Edie